bugünkü Dersim çok çok önemli polarlık
apolarlık Daha önce anlatmıştım ama
bugün polar molekül apolar molekülden
bahsedeceğim polar kovalent bağ apolar
kovalent bağdan Farklı durumlar da söz
konusu ilk başta sanki aynıymış gibi
gidiyor ama sonra bazı şeyler değişecek
çok önemli kurallardan bahsedeceğim
polar molekülü apolar molekülü
öğrendiğinde daha sonraki zayıf
etkileşimler kısmında yani moleküller
arası Bağlar kısmında rahat edeceksin o
yüzden Bu ders çok önemli dikkatli
dinlemeni istiyorum tabii öyle boş boş
izlememek lazım değil mi Not Alman da
gerekiyor o yüzden PDF nerede olacak
Açıklama kısmında olacak bazen sitede
Güncelleme yaparken gecikmeler
olabiliyor O yüzden Şimdiden özür
diliyorum Bir de şu kanala abone olursan
çok mutlu olurum Hadi O Zaman başlayalım
şimdi moleküllerin polarlığı apolarlığı
da birkaç tane kuralımız vardır Birisi
iki tane atom içeren moleküller Burada
da Farklı durumlar var onu söyleyeceğim
bir de çok atom içeren moleküller var
ikisin dei durumları da anlatacağım önce
iki atomlu moleküllerden bahsedeceğim
Ama polarlık apolarlık ne demektir bir
onu hatırlayalım istersen neydi apolar
kovalent bağ vardı kutuplaşmanın
olmadığı moleküllerde gerçekleşiyordu bu
e polar kovalent bahaneydi kutuplaşmanın
olduğu durumda vardı yani farklı atomlar
bir araya geldiğinde ne oluyordu
elektronegatiflikleri farklı olduğu için
kutuplaşma meydana geliyordu Bundan
dolayı da Bağ polar oluyordu bağ ne
diyoruz ona polar kovalent bağ oluyordu
ama aynı ametal atomları birleştiğinde
Bunların elektronegatiflikleri aynı
olduğu için ne oluyordu bağ apolar
kovalent bağ oluyordu burada da bunu
söylüyor işte aynı tür ametal atomlar
arasında apolar kovalent bağ farklı
ametal atomlar arasındaysa ne oluyordu
işte polar kovalent bağ oluşuyordu fakat
Molekülün polarlığı apolarlığı durum
şudur Şuradaki tanımlar çok önemlidir
Bunu bilmekte fayda var sorularda bu
şekilde kullanılıyor elektron yoğunluğu
dengeli bir şekilde dağılıyorsa apolar
molekül ama dengeli bir şekilde
dağılmıyorsa polar molekül şeklinde
ifade ediyoruz şimdi bunların
detaylarından bahsedeceğim burada
konunun içerisinde Levis gösteriminde
molekül üzerinde elektronun yük
yoğunluğunun ne tarafa doğru olduğunu
göstermek için şöyle Oklar kullanacağız
yani elektronegatiflik büyük olan atoma
doğru böyle ok çizeceğiz O yüzden
şimdiden bu okun ne demek istediğini de
burada anlatmış olayım Şimdi 2i atomlu
moleküllerde şöyle yazıyoruz 2 atomlu
moleküllerde atomlar aynı ise molekül
apolar atomlar ya da yazayım ya Niye şey
yapıyorum ki he atomlar farklı ise
molekül polardır Çünkü atomlar aynı
olduğunda yük yoğunluğu dengeli dağılır
ama farklı olduğunda yük yoğunluğu
dengesiz olacaktır dengeli dağılmayacak
o zaman da polar
olacaktır ya bu
Kargulu Neyse ben Şunlara bakıp
geliyorum Evet geldim şimdi devam
edebiliriz şimdi buradaki şeyi tekrar
söylüyorum iki atomlu moleküllerde
atomlar aynıysa molekül apolar farklıysa
polar diyoruz Şimdi istersen örnekler
üzerinde açıklayalım H2 F2 N2 O2 gibi
bak aynı ametal atomlarından oluşuyor
burada hem Bağlar apolar kovalent bağ
hem de molekül apolar oluyor şöyle bir
şey vardı neydi flor işte 9d değil mi
nasıl yazılıyordu 1 S2 2 S2 2p 5i yani
değerlik elektron sayısı ya da valans
elektron sayısı 7'di E ne oluyordu bu
işte son katmanında 7 tane nokta
koyuyorduk işte 1 2 3 4 önce 4 tane
birer tane işte ne yapıyorduk 4 yönüne
birer taneyi
yerleştiriyorsunuz diğer flor atomu aynı
şekilde yapılıyordu onu da yazayım
istersen onu da farklı renkte göstermek
istiyorum Diğer flor atomu Hani o tek
noktaları karşılıklı denk getirmek
istiyorum 1 2 3 4 Sonra işte 5 6 7 oldu
mesela işte şunlar ne yapıyordu bağı
oluşturuyordu bak buradaki görüntüyü
oluşturuyor şimdi ikisinin de
elektronegatifliği eşit olduğu için ne
olacak elektronları bu kendi tarafına
doğru çekmek isteyecek Bu da kendi
tarafına çekecek Ne oldu işte yük
yoğunluğu dengeli oldu bak ortada kaldı
o yüzden yüzden molekül apolarda diyoruz
Yani aynı ametal atomlarından
oluştuğunda molekül apoları yapıştır geç
dostum Bu arada ufak bir hatırlatma
yapmak istiyorum Bu Levis yapısında bu
7i tane nokta var ya bazısı şöyle
yapmaya kalkıyor Hocam ben şöyle yapsam
olur mu işte şöyle bak üçer tane koysam
böyle yapsam olur mu Olmaz bak önce
birer tane yerleştiriyorsunuz
şu şekilde yani Hocam illa Buraya mı
Yook şöyle de olabilir Böyle de
kalabilir Olabilir bak bu doğrusudur
şöyle yapanlar görüyorum bazen de şu
şekilde yapıyorlar şöyle şöyle ya
Arkadaş yanına koysana niye böyle saçma
sapan bir görüntü yapıyorsun yani o iki
nokta şöyle Yan Yana Bak şeyi sembolün
çevresini sarıyorsun bu şekilde
gösterilmekte bunu da ekstradan
hatırlatmak istedim ha başka bir tane
molekül O2 molekülü vardı oksijen neydi
1 S2 2 S2 2p 4'tü 6a grubu olduğu için
değerlik elektron sayısı 6'yı Yani 6
tane nokta yazacağız nasıl yapıyorduk o
oksijeni önce birer tane 1 2 3 4 Sonra
ne yapıyoruz işte 5 6 böyle yapabiliriz
Bak iki tane tek noktası var E diğer
oksijeni de düşün diğer oksijenin de iki
tane tek noktası olacak şu şekilde E o
zaman ne yapacak şunlar şöyle bağlanacak
iki tane bağ yaptı e iki tarafta da
oksijen atomu var E oksijen atomlarının
Her ikisi de eşit güçte bu ortak
kullanılan elektronları eşit güçte
çekeceği için Molekül ne olacaktır
apolar olacaktır burada hem Bağlar Apo
kovalent onu yazalım apolar kovalent bağ
hem de molekül apolar olacaktır Bunu
unutma dostum aynı durum N2 molekülünde
de var ama N2 molekülünü yazarken önce
şunu yapalım 1 S2 2 S2 2p 3'tü 5A grubu
olduğu için değerlik elektron sayısı 5 1
2 3 4 5 böyle yazabilirim mesela diğer
bir Azot atomu ne oldu işte 1 2 3 4 5
böyle yazdım şunlar bağ yaptı Bak tek
noktalar bağ yaptı işte 3 tane bağ
yapıldı ortak kullanılan elektronlar iki
tarafta da azot olduğu için ne olacak
eşit güçte çekilecek ve yük yoğunluğu
tam ortada yani dengeli olacak dostum
ama bir de şöyle bir şey var Farklı
ametal atomlarından oluşursa mesela HF
hcl bak HF HC co O iki atomlu ama
atomlar birbirinden farklı İşte bu da
hem Bağları polar kovalent oluyor hem de
molekül polar oluyor şöyle gösterelim
hcl üzerinden gösterelim Bu neydi 1 S1
Yani bunun Levis yapısı tek nokta e Klor
ne kloru da şuraya yazayım 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S2 3 P5 7A grubu olduğu için klorda
da 7 tane nokta var 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 E bak
şunlar bağ yapacak şöyle arasında bağ
yapacaklar şöyle sileyim de şu şekilde
göstereyim Aha bak hile CL şöyle bağı
yaptı çok güzel e klorun
elektronegatifliği 7A grubu olduğu için
daha fazla O yüzden ne yapacak biliyor
musun ortak kullanılan elektronlar kime
daha yakın olacak Burada klora daha
yakın olacak yani yük yoğunluğu dengeli
dağılmamış olduğu için elektronlar klora
daha yakın olduğundan dolayı o taraf
eksi hidrojen tarafı da ne olacak artı
olacak kutuplaşma var mı var o zaman yük
yoğunluğu dengeli dağılmadı gördün mü
bir tarafa doğru daha fazla oldu Bundan
dolayı ne diyoruz buna polar molekül
diyoruz Hem şu bağ bak şu bağ polar
kovalent bağ yazalım polar kovalent bağ
hem de molekül polar oluyor zaten çok
basit İki atomlarda atomları aynıysa ne
diyoruz apolar molekül farklıysa polar
molekül diyoruz bak şu ifade gerçekten
çok önemli ne diyor bak bir molekülde
elektron yoğunluğunun simetrik
dağılmaması sebebi temel nedeni Merkez
atomda bağ yapmamış değerlik
elektronlarının bağ yapmış elektron
çiftlerine uyguladığı itme kuvvetidir
diyor o zaman ben buradan şunu anlamış
oluyorum yük yoğunluğunun dengeli
dağılmaması için Merkez atomda bu bağ
yapmayan elektron olması gerekiyor gibi
bir anlam çıkıyor burada işte çok atom
atomlu moleküllerdeki durum da bu onu
yazalım şuraya çok atomlu moleküllerde
merkez atomda yani diğer atomların
bağlandığı atomdan bahsediyoruz Merkez
atomda
ortaklaşması hiç bilmiyorum Mesela bak
şöyle yazdım x yazdım y yazdım y ya
yazdım y yazdım şuraya şunları koydum
Hatta tamam böyle bırakabilirim dedi ki
bu molekül polar mı Apolar mı bak Çok
basit burada Merkez atom hangisidir x
Hocam nereden anladın Çünkü diğer
atomların bağlandığı atoma Merkez atom
diyoruz bağ sayısı fazla olana Merkez
atom diyoruz burada x Merkez atom bak
Merkez atomda görüyor musun
ortaklaşması elektron çifti He o zaman
bu Molekül ne olacaktır polar olacaktır
dostum tamam mı Peki hocam bana bir de
apolar örneği göster hemen gösteriyorum
x yazdım şöyle y dedim Şöyle y dedim
Şöyle y dedim Şunların çevresine
noktalar koydum Bunu özellikle yapıyorum
dostum diyeceksin ki A hocam bak
ortaklaşması açıklayacağım sana bak ne
dedim Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması molekül polar yoksa apolar
Aha sana Merkez atom x x de boşta
elektron görüyor musun görmüyorsun
ortaklaşması bakmıyorum Merkez atoma
bakıyorum Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması ametal atomları arasında
oluşan bağ polar kovalent bağ değil mi
miydi kovalent bağ Evet doğru ama hocam
moleküle apolar dedin bak Molekülün
polarlığı apolarlığı la bağın polarlığı
apolarlığı aynı şey değil bak çok önemli
bir şeyden bahsediyorum bunu böyle can
kulağıyla dinle istersen bir kere daha
dinle Ne oluyor Molekülün polarlığın da
Merkez atoma bakıyorum Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması polar hiç bağın türüne
bakmadan merkez atomda
ortaklaşması yakıştırıyorsa bağın
polarlığı apolarlığı geçen derste
öğrettiğim gibi onda sıkıntı yok aynı
ametal atomları apolar farklı ametal
atomları polar şeklinde söylüyorsun onda
Herhangi bir problem yok zaten o
kovalent bağ şeklinde söylüyoruz bu
Molekülün polarlığı apolarlığı tamam mı
dostum bu şeyi Grup numarasını şunu bunu
bilmeden yaptığın örneklerde direkt buna
bakıyorsun Eyvallah bunda hiçbir sorun
yok Peki sana dedi ki şöyle yazdı hemen
örnekle yazacağım H2O bak çok atomlu Bir
molekül H2O 3 tane atom var burada Ne
oluyor hidrojenler oksijene bağlanıyor
Neden Çünkü oksijen 6a Grubu 2 bağ
yapabiliyor iki tane tek noktası var
hatta hemen şuraya yazayım oksijen neydi
1 S2 2 S2 2p 4'tü şöyle bir Levis yapısı
vardı şu şekilde noktaları yerleştirdim
iki tane tek noktası var hidrojenler
gelip buraya bağlanıyor Çünkü hidrojen 1
S1 di yani şöyleydi yani H2O görüntüsü
nasıl oluyor şöyle oluyor işte Bak şu
çiftler onu da farklı renkle yapayım ki
karışmasın bak şunlar ne yapıyor biliyor
musun İşte yük yoğunluğunun dengeli
dağılmasını engelliyor O yüzden bu
Molekül ne oluyor molekül polar oluyor
çünkü merkez atomda
söylüyorum can kulağıyla dinle birazdan
Altını da çizeceğim zaten Eğer Merkez
atom Grup numarası kadar bağ yapıyorsa
molekül apolar Grup numarasından daha az
bağ yapıyorsa molekül polardır ama aynı
ametal atomu ile yapacak yani sadece
hidrojenler veya işte sadece flor Neyse
artık şimdi 6a grubu elementi o zaman
yapabileceği maksimum bağ sayısı kaç
oluyor 6 oluyor değil mi Grup numarası
kadar hani Grup numarası 6a 6 bağ
yapmasını bekliyoruz ama H2O kaç bağ
yaptı 2 bağ yaptı bak Grup numarasından
daha az bağ yaptı değil mi o yüzden bu
Molekül ne oluyor polar oluyor Grup
numarasından az yapıyorsa polar Grup
numarası kadar bağ yapıyorsa apoları
yapıştır geç dostum aynı ametal atomları
la birleştiğinde Bak burada da işte bu
kuralı detaylı bir şekilde anlatıyorum
altını çizerek gideceğim Dostum bak
diyor ki Merkez atom değerlik
elektronlarının bir kısmını bir kısmı
ile bağ oluştururken Bir kısmıyla bağ
oluşumuna katılmıyorsun yani Merkez
atomda
ortaklaşması dengeli dağılmaz simetrik
olmaz O yüzden molekül polar olur
elektron yoğunluğu elektronegatifliği
büyük olan atomların olduğu yöne doğru
daha büyük olacaktır burada işte Molekül
ne olur tabii ki polar karakterli olur
Ama şöyle bir şey var işte Merkez atom
sahip olduğu tüm değerlik elektronlarını
Aynı tür ametal atomu ile ortaklaşa
kullandığında oluşan molekülde elektron
yoğunluğu simetrik dağılır yani Merkez
atom Grup numarası kadar bağ yaparsa
demektir Çünkü değerlik elektronlarının
hepsini bağa katıyor 6a grubu değerlik
elektron sayısı 6 6 ı bağ yaparsa o
molekül apolo oluyor çünkü Merkez atomda
ne olmuş oluyor
ortaklaşması oluyor bu durumda
örneklerle açıklayacağım zaten bunu İşte
bu durumda yük yoğunluğu dengeli
dağılacaktır yine polar kovalent bağ
apolar kovalent bağ onları açıklayacağım
ama Molekülün apolar olduğunu burada
söyleyebilirim Hemen şu yan tarafa
örneğiyle açıklıyorum Şimdi mesela bak
ne olsun karbon olsun karbon 6 1 S2 2 S2
2 P2 4A grubu değil mi dedi ki ch4
molekülü polar mıdır apolar mıdır bak
hidrojen 1 bağ yapabiliyor karbon 4 bağ
yapabiliyor o zaman ch4 dediğimiz
molekül aha böyle bir moleküldür şimdi
dikkat et 4A grubuyuz kaç bağ yaptı 4
bağ yaptı o yüzden bu Molekül ne diyoruz
molekül apolar diyoruz başka bir örnek
bak ph3 diyorum ph3 ya da dur ph3
demeyeyim
pcl3 Hım Başka örnek bir de pcl 5
diyorum şimdi p dediğim 15 1 S2 2 S2 2 2
P6 3 S2 3p 3 yani 5A grubu elementi Hım
dikkat Yani bunun 5 tane noktası olacak
1 2 3 4 5 tane noktası var peki burada
C'yi de yazalım CL 17 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3
S2 3p 5 Bu da 7A grubu elementi bunda da
7 tane nokta olacak şu şekilde 7 tane
nokta olacak o zaman Klor bir bağ
yapabiliyor şu tek noktalara bakarak
söyler sanki fosfor şu anda 3 bağ
yapabiliyor bu tek noktalardan dolayı o
zaman bak pcl3 dediğimizde şöyle olmaz
mı klorla Bağları yaptı Klor bir bağ
yaptı şunlar da böyle yaptı bak yazdım
Ahan şu şekilde He tamam şunda da iki
tane nokta var Bak bir bu molekül var
Bir de pcl5 diyor Bak demek ki klorla 5
bağ yapıyor yani şöyle bak bu Molekülün
şeklini bilmek zorunda değilsin korlar
bu C'nin şey pardon P'nin tüm değerlik
elektronlarını alarak Aha böle böyle bir
molekül oluşturdu şimdi dikkatlice
seyret beni burada Merkez atomda var mı
ortaklaşması boş de değerlik elektronu
yok hepsini kullandı O yüzden bu Molekül
ne olacaktır apolar olacaktır Değerli
dostum şimdi Yukarıdaki örnekten
başlayıp aşağı doğru tekrar gideceğim Şu
bağa bakar mısın kimle kim arasında
oluşuyor karbonla hidrojen farklı ametal
atomu mu Evet O yüzden bu bağ nedir
polar kovalent bağdır kovalent bağ yani
Bak yine söylüyorum bağın polarlığı
apolarlığı ile Molekülün polarlığı
apolarlığı Aynı şey değildir Bak molekül
apolar ama Bağları Ne oldu polar oldu Şu
aşağıya geldim bak P ile CL arasında
farklı ametal atomları ne olacaktır bu
polar kovalent bağ olacaktır aynı durum
şurası için de geçerli bak şu Bağlar
polar kovalent bağ olacaktır Ama
gördüğün gibi pcl3 Ne oldu polar molekül
oldu ama pcl5 tüm değerlik
elektronlarını kullandığı için yani 5
bağ yaptığı için Grup numarası kadar bağ
yaptığı için molekül apolar oldu tamam
mı dostum şimdi gel H2O tekrar yaklaştım
ilk başta bunu anlatmıştım şimdi
moleküller üzerinden anlatıyorum şimdi
oksijeni yazmışız Tamam hidrojenler le
bağ yaptı Normalde oksijenin
elektronegatifliği hidrojenden nedir
büyüktür O yüzden burada ne olacaktır
elektronlar Kime Doğru oksijene doğru
daha çok çekilecektir oksijen tarafı
eksi yüklü olacaktır hidrojen tarafı
artı yüklü olacaktır Ve merkez atomda
bak Farklı renkle göstereyim onu da H
Merkez atomda var mı
ortaklaşması polar olacaktır dostum
mesela nh3 molekülü var şimdi azot 1 S2
2 S2 2p 3'tür yani 5A grubu elementidir
e 5A grubu elementi şimdi hidrojen bir
bağ yapmak istiyor E burada azot 5A
grubu olduğu halde kaç bağ yapmış 3 bağ
yapmış görüyor musun 1 2 3 bağ yapmış e
Grup numarası 5 ama 3 bağ yaptı yani
Grup numarasından daha az bağ yaptı Hiç
bak moleküle bakmadan da yapıştırır
Geçerim Ne oldu polar molekül diye
yapıştırırım ama moleküle baktığımda
zaten gözüküyor azotun üzerinde Gördüğün
gibi ne var burada işte elektron var
yani
ortaklaşması almayacaktır polar molekül
olacaktır Bu da aynı şeyi burada bak Heh
molekülü burada gösteriyor işte bu ok
yönleri ne demekti elektronun
yoğunluğunun olduğu tarafı gösteriyordu
azot kısmen negatif hidrojen kısmen
pozitif Neden Çünkü elektron negatiflik
azot büyük hidrojendir Bundan dolayı ha
bak geldik ch4 molekülüne karbon neydi 1
S2 2 S2 2 P2 4A grubu elementi o zaman 4
bağ yaparsa bu moleküle ne deriz apolar
deriz 4 bağdan daha az yaparsa polar
diyebiliriz değil mi Hım şimdi o zaman
bak burada gördün mü 4 bağ yapmış Aha da
1 2 3 4 bağ yapmış Eyvallah E bundan
dolayı Ne olacak bu molekül apolar
olacak çünkü yük yoğunluğu dengeli
dağılmış Tamam burada karbon eksi yük
hidrojenler artı yüklü onda sıkıntı yok
Ama ben bunu neye benzetiyorum biliyor
musun Bak yakından göstereyim şöyle bir
molekül düşün kalemi düşürmem İnşallah
biraz pahalı Çünkü biliyorsunuz şöyle
tuttum Bak şöyle diyelim yük yoğunluğu
diyelim şu taraflarda olsun Şu ortadaki
ne olsun Ne olsun ya da yok şey olsun ya
şöyle diyelim e Heh yük yoğunluğu burada
dengeli Görüyor musun E Şuradaki karbon
olsun şunlar da oksijen olsun mesela ne
oluyor oksijenin elektronegatifliği
büyük olduğu için elektronlar bu
taraflara doğru bak çekiliyor ama yük
yoğunluğu dengeli dağıldığı için kalem
böyle duruyor ama mesela Neyi örnek
vereyim işte H2O daki durumu örnek
vereyim H2O daki durum şu elektron
yoğunluğu ne yapıyor şey tarafında daha
fazla oluyor oksijen tarafında dengesiz
oluyor kalem düşmesin diye tutuyorum
biraz pahalı Ne yapayım Allah Allah
idare et Yani bu elimle destekleyerek
gösteriyorum Bak burada yük yoğunluğu
dengeli değil işte Heh moleküle geri
dönüyorum bu molekülde Tamam ne oluyor
Karbonun elektronegatifliği hidrojenden
büyük olduğu için karbon tarafı negatif
elektron o tarafa doğru çekiliyor
hidrojen tarafları pozitif ama bak ne
oluyor deminki o kalemin dengede durması
gibi düşün ne oluyor bir yük yoğunluğu
dengesi var çünkü Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması Buradan da yakalayabilirsin
tamam mı dostum iki durum var ne diyoruz
o zaman hatırlıyoruz Bak sürekli
hatırlamamız gereken bir Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması yoksa apolar diyoruz veya
diğer yöntem Merkez atom Grup numarası
kadar bağ yapıyorsa apolar diyoruz Grup
numarasından daha az bağ yapıyorsa polar
diyoruz Bak bu da önemli bir ayrıntı
bunu da söyledik Heh burada yük
yoğunluğu simetrik dağıldığı için apolar
moleküldür şeklinde ifade ediyor burada
da göstermiş Aha CO2 molekülü benim en
sevdiğim moleküllerden bir tanesi dikkat
et Şimdi karbon 4A grubuyuz şöyle 4 bağ
yapmak istiyor E oksijen 6a grubuyuz Bu
da ne yapıyor iki bağ yapıyordu değil mi
geneldeki söylüyorum şöyle iki tane tek
noktası olduğu için E ne olacak o zaman
karbon 2 elektronunu kimle bir oksijenle
diğer iki elektronunu diğer oksijenle
ortak kullandı kullanmadıkları bak
şunlar hala duruyor etrafında oksijenin
iler duruyor ama karbon tamamını
kullandı Merkez atom kim burada karbon
değil mi dostum Grup numarası kaçtı 4'tü
e kaç bağ yaptı 1 2 3 4 bağ yaptı O
zaman bu molekül
apolarda şu gelebilir hocam CO2 dedik
sanki karbon 2 bağ yapmış gibi duruyor E
bir dakika Hayır 4 bağ yapıyor Neden
Çünkü oksijen 2 bağ yapmak istiyor E iki
tane oksijen varsa o zaman karbon kaç
bağ yapmış oluyor 4 bağ yapmış oluyor
değil mi İşte buradan yakalıyorsun tamam
mı dostum CO2 molekülü apolar moleküldür
buna çok benzeyen bir molekül var o da
Mesela cs2 molekülüdür şöyle göstereyim
Çünkü s de 6a grubu mesela cs2 molekülü
deseydi yine Ne diyecektik buna apolar
molekül diyecektik Çünkü Merkez atom
olan karbon Grup numarası kadar bağ
yapmış tekrar hatırlatıyorum şu Bağlar
nedir polar kovalent kovalent bağ
yazamadım L Bir dakika dur kovalent bağ
niye polar kovalent bağ Çünkü birisi
karbon biri oksijen bağın polarlığı ap
polarlığın Tekrar hatırlatalım eğer aynı
ametal atomları birleşiyorsa apolar
farklı ametal atomları birleşiyorsa
polar diyorduk şimdi gel sana çok önemli
bir tablo yapayım şöyle polar moleküller
diyeceğim polar molekül Bir de apolar
molekül diyeceğim Bazı arkadaşlar ezberi
seviyor Onlar için bir şey olsun böyle
tablo olsun şöyle bir şey var ne
demiştik ilk olarak iki atomlu
moleküllerde atomlar aynı değilse yani
hcl HF hbr h ı c o n bak Farklı ametal
atomları birleşerek oluşturuyor iki
atomlu molekül İki atom var sadece c ne
var şey var burada Pardon c ve o var n
ve o var hani iki atomlu moleküller ne
oluyor atomlar farklıysa hem Bağları
polardır hem de molekül polardır ama
atomlar aynıysa N2 O2 F2 CL2 br2 ı2 H2
gibi gibi gibi aynı ametal atomlarından
oluşuyorsa apolar molekülü
yapıştırıyoruz geçiyoruz rengini
değiştirdim dedim ki ikiden fazla atomlu
yani Çok atomlu moleküllerde ama iki
cins atom içerecek mesela H2O oksijen
Merkez atomdur Grup numarası 6a olmasına
rağmen 2 bağ yaptı Grup numarasından az
bağ yaptığı için ne diyorduk polar
molekül diyorduk s de mesela 6a grubu o
zaman h2s de ne olacaktır polar molekül
olacaktır benzediği için mesela Bun
değil mesela nh3 yazmıştık nh3 nedir bu
işte polar moleküldür Çünkü 5 A grubu
olmasına rağmen 3 bağ yapıyor merkez
atomda
nf3 verebilirim yine 5A grubunda ph3 ü
ya da işte pcl 3'ü örnek olarak
verebilirim Bunlar arttırılabilir apolar
kısma geldiğimizde ise ne demiştik ch4
benzediği için ccl4 bunu da örnek
verebilirim Başka mesela Bor var bak Bor
bh3 Bor e yarım metalde hidrojenli
bileşikleri kovalent Eee ya Daha doğrusu
şöyle söyleyeyim polarlık apolarlık Tan
bahsedebilir mesela pH bh3 ne olacaktır
apolar molekül olacaktır Çünkü B 3A
grubu elementi 3 ba yapmış apolar
olacaktır değil mi Başka Mesela neyi
örnek verebiliriz CO2 yi benzediği için
C s2'ye örnek olarak verebiliriz böyle
kalsın Bunlar mesela peki peki peki
başka neyden bahsedelim Bir de ekstra
bir kural daha söylüyorum o da ne hatta
renk de bu sefer siyah olsun Eğer ü
farklı ametal atomu görürsen örnek
veriyorum
Ch3 Cl burada ne var Bak karbon var
hidrojen var Klor var yapıştır polar
molekül veya ch3oh
ne var C var H var O var ü farklı cins
ametal atomunu gördüğünde yapıştır oraya
Neyi polar polar molekül evet he
söyleyemedim polar molekülü hcn polar
molekül mesela Ch3 cooh sirke
asidiyle kül veya C2 h5 Oh gibi gibi
gibi ü farklı cins atomu gördüğünde
yapıştır polar molekülü Bir de şu vardır
sadece c ve
htane C6 H6 ch4 c2h 2 C2 H6 C3 h8 sadece
c ve htane de apoları yapıştır geç
dostum tamam mı hocam Bak burada da şey
var diyebilirsin hocam Bak burada da c
ve H var ama burada o da var sadece c ve
htane Al sana mis gibi polarlık
apolarlık tablosu Ha şimdi soru çözelim
diyor ki bak hidrojen karbon azot
oksijen flor elementleri ne yapıyormuş
işte yaptıkları bileşikler ile ilgili
olarak hangisi yanlıştır bak HF iki
atomlu ve atomlar birbirinden farklı
şöyle HF şu Bağ nedir Farklı ametal
atomlar arasında olduğu için polar
kovalent bağdır bağı sorduğu için polar
kovalent bağ molekülü sorsaydı O da
polardır zaten tık bu doğru N2
molekülünde atomlar arasında apolar
kovalent bağ vardır N2 molekülünde azot
atomları 3 bağ yapıyordu E ne oldu aynı
ametal atomlar arasında ne oluyordu
apolar kovalent bağ oluyordu doğru diyor
ki H2O apolar bileşiktir H2O oyu
Sabahtan beri çizdiğim için tekrar şey
yapıyorum böyle direkt yazıyorum H2O
buydu bak Bağları polar kovalent bağ
onda sıkıntımız yok E Merkez atomda var
mı
ortaklaşması Apolar demiş Yok artık daha
neler gitti ch4 diyor ki kovalent bağı
içerir ya karbon ametal değil mi
hidrojen de ametal e ametal ametal
arasında ne oluyordu kovalent bağ
oluyordu Hatta Keşke polarlık apolarlık
da deseydi şöyle yazayım Bak hidrojen
hidrojen hidrojen hidrojen Bak farklı
ama metal atomları arasında olduğu için
hatta buna polar kovalent bağ şeklinde
de ne yapabiliriz söyleyebiliriz Yani bu
ifade Doğrudur CO2 molekülü apolarda CO2
nasıldı çizdiğim için tekrar hemen
yapıyorum şöyle CO2 molekülü buydu
Merkez atom karbon 4A grubu elementi ve
burada gördüğün gibi 1 2 3 4 bağ yapmış
bir buradan yakalayabilirsin bir de
merkez atomda
Doğrudur biz yanlışı bulduk cevap C
seçeneğidir Oh mis bana molekülü komple
vermiş Bak ilk molekülde Merkez atom
oksijenmetre
külü ben birazcık daha böyle gözün e
rahat alışsın diye şöyle göstermek
istiyorum E şimdi Buraya bakarsak
molekülde merkez atomda
ortaklaşması ikinci de Merkez atom
karbon karbon oksijenle ikişer bağ
yapmış Bak 1 2 bağ yapmış şöyle yapmış e
Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması kadar bağ yapmış bu neydi
apolar moleküldür üçüncüye bakalım
karbon ortada bak ne yapmış klorla
bağlanmış şöyle bağlanmış çok güzel şu
şekilde gösterelim e Merkez atom karbon
e karbonda var mı
vardır apolar molekül şimdi bakalım y ve
z molekülleri apolar karakterlidir doğru
diyor ki x molekülünde elektron
yoğunluğu dengeli dağılmamıştır dengeli
dağıldığında apoları dengeli
dağılmamıştır dediği için polardır evet
polar olduğu için bu ifade de doğrudur
moleküllerin üçünde de apolar kovalent
bağ yoktur Doğrudur Çünkü bak Co farklı
ametal atomları polar kovalent bağ ne of
farklı ametal atomları polar kovalent B
ccl farklı ametal atomları polar
kovalent B Hiçbirinde polar kovalent
bağı yoktur doğru bak Molekülün
polarlığı apolarlığı başkaydı bağın
polarlığı apolarlığı başkaydı O yüzden
Doğrudur cevap 1 2 3 e seçeneği
olacaktır gelelim Bu sorumuza diyor ki
kovalent bağlı bileşikler ile ilgili
formüllerinde atom sayısı kadar atomlar
içeren moleküller oluştururlar Doğrudur
Çünkü şöyle bir şey var kovalent
bileşiklerde sayılar sadeleşmiş şöyle
örnek vereyim mesela C6 H6 diyoruz değil
mi kovalent bileşiklerde atom sayıları
sadeleşme iyonik bileşiklerde sadeleşir
mesela Mesela şöyle örnek vereyim
ag2 veya şöyle söyleyeyim ag2 demeyelim
ne örnek vereyim Bir saniye Dur farklı
bir örnek vereceğim pb2 o4 böyle bir şey
yazmazsın iyonik bileşiklerde sadeleşir
pbo2 yazarsın Yani atom sayısını tam
olarak anlayamazsın ama kovalent bağlı
bileşiklerde burada gerçek atom sayısını
vermektedir yani formüllerinde atom
sayısı kadar atom içeren moleküllerden
oluşur Kesinlikle doğru bir ifadedir
diyor ki molekül içi bağlarının tamamı
polar kovalent ise molekül polar
karakterlidir hemen istisnai örneklerini
gösteririm sana al sana Şuradaki ch4
molekülü şu Bağlara bakarsan polar
kovalent bağdır bu değil mi farklı
ametal atomlar arasında oluşuyor ama
moleküle baktığımızda Merkez atom
diyorduk değil mi Merkez atom burada
karbon e karbon 4A grubu ve 4 bağ yapmış
yani ne oldu molekül apolar oldu yazalım
şuraya Hah molekül apolar yani Bağları
polar olduğunda her zaman molekül de
polar olmak zorunda değilmiş gitti 2
atomlu ne diyor 2 atomlu olanları apolar
karakterlidir Tamam mesela F2
dediğimizde doğrudur ama hcl dediğimizde
yanlıştır yani atomlar aynıysa apolar
karakterli farklıysa polar karakterli
olur Bu da kesin değildir bundan dolayı
cevap Yalnız bir a seçeneği olacaktır
şuna bakalım Diyor ki hcl molekülüne ait
Yukarıdaki gösterimlerden hangileri
doğrudur diyor şimdi şöyle bir şey vardı
hcl'de Ne yapıyordu hidrojen bir bağ
yapıyordu hatta nasıl gösteriyordu şöyle
gösteriyordu kloru da 7 tane tane nokta
gösteriyordu 7A grubu elementi olduğu
için ikisi de bir bağ yapıyor O zaman
hidrojenle Klor arasında bir bağ olmalı
Burada 2 bağ göstermiş bu yanlış Evet
burada klorun elektronegatifliği 7A
grubu olduğu için hidrojenden daha
büyüktür E bundan dolayı da
elektronların yük yoğunluğu ne olacaktır
klora doğru olacaktır yani hcl
dediğimizde Klor tarafı eksi hidrojen
tarafı artı olacak ha burada Ters yazmış
gitti Heh Bak burada elektron yoğunluğu
burada şeklin şöyle görüntüsüne bakarak
söylüyorum E ne yapmış Klor tarafında
daha fazla hidrojen tarafında daha az
Bundan dolayı ne olacaktır üçüncüsü
doğru olacaktır cevabımız C seçeneğidir
Evet güzel insan bir ara verelim
polarlık apolarlık Tan bahsettik çok
önemli yerden bahsettik detaylarını Bak
tekrar hatırlatıyorum sana gel bir daha
üstünden geçelim iki atomlu moleküllerde
atomlar aynıysa apolar molekül farklıysa
polar molekül dedik Çok atomlu
moleküllerde ne yapıyorduk iki cinsi
atom içeriyor diyelim Merkez atom aynı
ametal atomu yla değerlik elektron
sayısı kadar bağ yapıyorsa yani grup gr
numarası kadar bağ yapıyorsa 6a grubu 6
bağ yapıyor mesela 5A grubu 5 bağ
yapıyor gibi Grup numarası kadar bağ
yapıyorsa ne oluyordu apolar molekül
oluyordu ama Grup numarasından daha az
bağ yapıyorsa bu durumda Merkez atomda
ortaklaşması sağlıyordu Bir de ne
demiştim üç farklı cins atomda yapıştır
polar molekül Sadece cvan oluşuyorsa
yapıştır apolar molekül demiştim önemli
detaylar bunlardı dostum bir de neydi
polar molekül dediğimizde yük yoğunluğu
dengeli dağılmamış diyorduk apolarda yük
yoğunluğu dengeli dağılmıştır ifadesi
kullanılıyordu sorulara karşına çıkarsa
bunlara dikkat et dostum Senden bir
isteğim var kanala abone olarak izlersen
ben bu içeriklere devam edeceğim Senin
desteğin benim için çok önemli 12 sınıfa
kadar seninle daha çok işimiz var Yeni
müfredatı sana böyle İlmek ilmek
işleyeceğim dostum bir sonraki dersimiz
bileşik adlandırma sakın kaçırma çok
önemli bir ders olacak iki fosfor bir
asit kimya Bu kadar basit görüşmek
üzere an